[Music]
today I want to show you the game
actually I played yesterday and because
we had a game us chess League match last
night and I played this game it's a it's
a very interesting game let's positional
game a lot of endgame ideas in this game
as well so my opponent is an
international master Jonathan schroer
from North Carolina and I'm playing with
the white pieces again played last night
at the US chess league here at the club
so d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 so I actually
played against the same opponent with
the same color last year at the US chess
Lake so I thought maybe he'll he'll play
again this line but he surprised me a
little bit I played nine f3 and in our
game last year he played d5 so we
transpose into the Queens gambit
declined last year but this year he
decided to play b6 it looked like he was
prepared because he was moving pretty
fast in the opening so I play g3 now
Bishop a4 come which basics comes in now
your pawn is under attack here now there
are a couple of different moves you can
try to play here what are the candidates
most here for white who knows this
opening and what are the candidates
Monsieur yes
b3 is one of the most popular moves
Queen c2 was popularized by the last
maybe five six years you know I analyzed
spend a lot of time analyzing hours and
hours actually this Queen c2 c5 d5
sacrifice align pan sacrificed line well
there is another move there I played
there is another move that I played here
b3 Queen Queen c2 are very popular yes
III not a very good move because we
already played g3 you have to play one
of them either
III or g3 but you play both then we can
have some lights core weaknesses so it's
not gonna be that good it's not gonna be
very bad but it's not gonna be good like
we're not gonna have opening advantage
here okay so which rule did I play here
because he no he attacked my pawn now he
wants to take it I don't want a plane
that you don't want to play Knight bTW -
here - passive because you play c5 okay
and your Center is not strong and Knight
is passive here so the move is
absolutely the move is Queen a force in
fact the reason he prepared this because
I played a couple of times recently this
line are played at Olympiad last year in
Turkey and also I played in a Chicago
panelists okay they're a couple of games
in the database here that show that I
played this line so that's why he
decided to play this and did some prep
work because he was moving pretty fast
but okay this is you know not just
opening you have to play afterwards also
so Queen a for now he goes back we
should be seven because he wants to play
c5 and he wants to make sure he's
covering the d5 square when he does that
okay so I go Bishop g2 now c5 and now
black wants to take on d4 and exchange
the last good bishops if you allow him
to do that it's just going to be an
equal position you're not gonna have
anything so you have to take on c5 here
pawn takes e5 Castle pre-standard move
Bishop e7 Knight c3 and the other games
I mentioned to you it was same exact
position Queen b6 and here looks like he
plays Queen b6 and attacking a putting
pressure on the pawn on b2 and looks
like I cannot develop the bishop because
if I develop Bishop you'll just take the
pawn so it's kind of an active move now
he played Queen b6 well what is the best
move here for white
it's very important you develop your
pieces to the most active squares here
yes
they should have four very good that's
what I play but now what do you have
against Queen takes b2 exactly Knight b5
and block is in big trouble now I have
two threats now do you see both did you
see both 97 ruk everyone guess what the
queen is trapped so you have to be very
careful when you capture this kind of
pawns because sometimes your queen can
get trapped okay so it could be a big
trouble so this is actually losing this
is just a losing line actually for him
so he cannot take so he played rugby 8
so so far yeah and I Peru KB 1 i same
exact thing I did in my other game
against a young junior Darvin young you
know pretty high ready player I think he
played here at the club
a couple of junior tournaments and so
the point of rupee one is this is played
by a bloody mere kramnik actually this
move so I look at one of his games
excellent game he defeated I think
Sergei Kuryakin
with this idea the point is you want to
play a tree before positional you want
to call a tree before in that game
against young I had a very good game I
want that game in a similar similar idea
but my opponent did some good prep work
because he improved on that game and
actually played a very interesting I
still haven't found you know I'm I'm
gonna spend more time analyzing because
it's likely somebody else gonna play
like this they're gonna see this game
because he played a good move Bishop she
shakes for a moment it looks like a
strange little bit move because it takes
away the knight on c6 but you should
know one thing the knight doesn't want
to go to c6 in this position because if
the night goes on c6 it will block the
bishop and also this six square is gonna
be weak so he doesn't really want to go
in 96 in this position okay so that's
why he played so this was his
preparation actually so he did a good
job because now I go Queen c2 and now he
played a very strong move Queen d7
because during the game I you know I
thought okay this may be questionable
you know but I couldn't see like how can
I take advantage of this but it makes a
lot of sense what he did now because now
he's putting pressure on this diagonal
but what is the most important thing
that he's doing after Queen b7 what is
this setup do besides putting that
pressure what is he preventing now what
is he preventing huh no no my minority
attack is only the Queens gambit
declined don't mix up the ideas in fact
yeah I am trying to do a similar thing
but that's little bit different here a3
before I can still do it but now it's
something else he stops a3 a3 you know
you can play a 5 even yeah I can't
really play that a3 before uh-huh
excellent stops efore because throughout
the rest of the game I was trying to
make this efore idea work but now he
stops in four and it's difficult for me
to do anything okay to to play this
afore wolf
so now Queen d7 now I play a tree now I
like to play before if I can play before
then I have a very good position okay
but he's not letting me do that now
again he comes up with the best move
here what is the best move here to
prevent in fact a5 you know gives me
that B 5 square in some point I'm not
sure if that's the best square okay now
in fact I think I'll be better if you
play a 5 I think after I exchange the
logic of bishops I will be slightly
better 986 see putting the knight on the
square looks like kind of strange
squares to put the knight honor but he
stops before and I cannot really play
before now and now we arrive to this
position that it's it's not easy to play
for both players because there is no
clear plan
here it's not like I want to just do
this it's not clear prom I cannot play
efore I cannot play before but what do
you do in a positions like this these
are kind of rare positions because you
know like like he also doesn't have a
good plan because it's not like he can
just play d5 no as soon as she plays d5
I go 95 is in big trouble so what do we
do in a positions like this when you
don't see a clear plan what you supposed
to do yes improve your pieces gain space
okay these things it's very important
improve and gain space now how do we
gain some space and make some
prophylactic moves I did a couple of
prophylactic moves here okay
okay so which move you think would be a
useful hdy you think it's useful h3
alright good I played h3 stopping Knight
g4 and also maybe I want to play Knight
g4 at some point okay it's not out of
question so he played d6 now another
another move I need here solid move
because it's a point he wants to go rook
b8 Queen b3 so I play b3 now useful move
now I play the h6
but for him also it's difficult because
it's it's hard to sit on a position and
just don't do anything because he was
spending a lot of time here he was
spending 10 15 minutes on each move here
and after him yeah he is and after my
next home he actually spent like more so
like he spent a lot of time here like
two minutes left so he was thinking so
what's the next one that is gonna make
him spend another 20 minutes
International Master Johnathan sure so
what is the idea that is gonna make him
spend more time now you don't have to
have a really strong idea but you have
to do something that to make him think
make him think he looked it too it's
possible but even if I double up my
rooks I don't know if I want to do that
because he pulled the knight back on the
8th and then he starts attacking me on a
B file it wasn't easy for me to you know
the game yesterday because it was you
know like this this part was very
difficult because it was like I had to
spend a lot of time too because I don't
have a clear plan yet when I already had
got a slightly better position then I
already I think I played better and
you'll see that part but this was not
easy moment here so what should I do now
yes
now be careful you know there's 94 ideas
we should have six sometimes no I just
want to gain more space it will be
useful in the endgame to have more space
okay
g4 yes and I've seen this idea before
this is not really weakening the
position is playable like many many top
players play this idea in a positions
like this when there is nothing to do
they gain some space like this okay so
this this idea has been played before
not exactly this position but in the
similar type of positions okay the guy
who plays this position with block is
like oh he likes to play this a lot okay
but there were some players who put a
lot of pressure on him also in on navara
beat him and some other strong players
so now after g4 he spent a lot of time
here because I actually I'm not even
threatening anything here I was a little
bit surprised that he spent most of his
time here and he left himself at like 2
minutes here maybe a little bit more but
but he did find the best pool actually
so he played 94 black needs to exchange
couple of pieces that way he can try to
equalize the game ok and he did almost
equalize the game now I had this idea
here risky idea but he had he was so low
on the clock that I was thinking maybe I
should you know kind of gamble here and
play this move but then I realized I
didn't have I just need to play the
proper proper move I had this move
before that I was trying to make it work
because if he takes I take looks like
wait a minute he can just take right
he's got two pieces on it if it takes
root before but this line is not very
good for me actually
he takes 94 he's got this move Bishop a4
now then I actually went ahead I didn't
stop here I felt Queen d2 here but I
didn't like this position after Queen c4
I thought he has a easy game and he's
gonna start pushing this a pawn and I
didn't see like what do I have here yeah
Bishop c2 bish before dropping the night
so and plus this is this is you don't
want to play like this
forcing lines you know when opponent is
long time because you know he can make
the moves kind of quickly so you want to
make him thing so I played Knight takes
bishop takes before doesn't work anyway
and now I know I didn't blunder
I didn't blunder exchange here what is
my idea why I did this and after this
move he spend actually most of his time
now and he was just down to the
increment now after my next move because
it was not easy for him to decide
because he goes this way he's slightly
worse he goes other way he's slightly
worse and he went a different way here
here where he made a dubious mawatha my
next move
so what is the move here excellent move
91 yes exchanging that strong bishop so
when I mentioned he can go one way or
another way I was referring to Bishop g2
or Bishop CTO let's take a look at both
lines if he plays Bishop g2 I got a g2
now finally I want to play this move
before I played before I put my knight
only three I'm pressing him it's
probably very slightly better for me and
if you pleased if I buy take he takes
now sentries a little bit loose and I
have a good outpost for my knight when I
five and again this Knight is on the rim
so this is actually comfortable for me
slightly better again so he didn't want
to do that and he realized if I play for
his worse so the other option is he
could have taken here but he slightly
was here again so he didn't want to be
worse here and there so he played
something else so I think he takes this
is the best move I take Knight is
hanging so he cannot afford to lose the
knight has to go here take take and
actually here I'm pressing after before
in my opinion he should have played this
line this is his best chance here to
have you note when try to equalize here
because here I'm slightly better more
comfortable to play but you know he has
he has good
chances to equalize here okay sure he
should have gone for this line what what
he played it's not that bad either defy
very interesting you know the reason he
played this because this line black is
very passive usually just sitting there
and finally he realized okay I have this
chance to push up on and do something
active and he decided to give it a try
now my next one was pretty much forced
Bishop takes politics but how do you
play this position it's unusual
structure you know it's night is on the
rim but my night is only one my night is
not good only one in this position here
I'm slightly better very slightly better
but next one is very important move to
play so what is the next move here for
white if you were playing this position
now what would you do here yes 92 it's a
very very normal move it's probably a
fine move to play here but I had this
idea my might he wants to go Bishop f6
ish he wants to control this diagonal
okay so he wants to really control this
so what you gonna try to do here to
prevent his Bishop from getting active
take it first right and by doing that
you're centralizing your piece okay so
the move is Bishop e5 and again this
kind of positions you should never be
afraid of f6 move okay don't think oh
you place f6 f6 is good for you because
now it's weakening his position can you
actually want to induce this move
okay you want him to play off six okay
because he is very solid here I want to
create some weaknesses so I can win
because in order to win I have to create
some weaknesses or I have to win with a
plan that I did in the game I'm not
gonna tell the plan yet because I want
you to find it so again he is very alone
the clock and not easy to move
so he takes I take he goes rook t8 so he
deciding to exchange some pieces but
again this night is kind of awkward now
this night if this night was all c6 it
would be equal but he's couple of
temples behind here and sometimes that
couple of temples they make a big
difference so I didn't see anything
concrete so I just took alright okay
he took back with the bishop and now now
what do you do well the bish was already
centralized so bishop is fine now look
at the position carefully what do you
need to do here improve the night yeah
I'm not going to be able to win this
game with the night only one so I have
to improve the night where g2 nigt again
it's not so clear even where the night
is going yet here okay it could go a 4-h
5 it will go to e3 but now he goes
Bishop c7 this is the important moment
now opponent plays Bishop c7 what do you
do in this position he is offering the
exchange of the bishops so you have a
choice
take all retreat
but also you have to look at the
position also the fact that he is law on
the clock okay he is about two minutes I
have about 20 minutes here retreat why
why you think it's better to retreat
that's sure
besides instantly when opponent is loan
the clock you want to keep more pieces
on the board okay because if you
simplify then it's easier for him to
play now he needs to watch out for all
the bishop moves okay oh you mean this
one
yeah well that's that's yeah I'm not
sure how important that is but yeah
that's that's an idea and also there is
another reason the knight is on the rim
by taking you're letting him come into
the game okay it's I don't think there
is anything here if I take so I go
bishops bishops III okay why do you
think I go to c3 not on b2 exactly to
control it be four squares so in some
point I play before right because my
advantage is because I have three paths
on the Queen side he has two and I have
to use that that's that's the only way I
can win this game here I'm not gonna win
in the center I'm not gonna be able to
win this efore pawn so now he goes Queen
to c6 he sees the idea of before so he
goes Quincy seeks to prevent that now
prep it
absolutely improving the night improving
the night and again his night is still
on the rim night is still on the rim get
very important now something like this
I'm not gonna even worry about I'm
actually gonna pick up the central pawn
he's gonna give me a check I calculate
this line I'm gonna go here there is no
checkmate
we are covering this check cycle and I
think this is actually pretty much
losing for him because this pieces are
just awkward and Queen b7 is coming next
and if I'm not winning immediately I
will probably win an endgame I will win
some pounds at least
okay so my king escapes to safety and
his pieces are still awkward so now he
sees he cannot do anything else before
so he goes here now before finally we
play before remember we were keep we
were trying to do this in the opening
finally we play this 9 plays a6 he is
stopping it because my idea to put the
pawn on b5 then I'm happy
he put the pawn on d5 game is over I
play 45 but he plays a6 stopping it
this is a game where you need to improve
your position move by move this is only
slightly better here but now I want to
take that slightly better position to
big advantage and then after that take
it to a winning position
excellent why do you go queen bee -
excellent gaining a tempo and and what
else you do with queen bee - you are
forcing him to use weakness weakening
the position that's what you're forcing
and you're doing this with the tempo
okay
queen bee - attacking this pawn so he
has to do something he has to react okay
so he played a move f6 and now excellent
b5 now I go squinty six threatening to
go to h2
excellent night f1 night is going back
defending against the threat but later
on he wants to go to a better square on
d2 now he goes 97 he doesn't want to
take because then I take back with a
pond and I have to connect it passed
pawns so he goes here and I believe this
is a very important move my plate
because if I don't play this move here
it's still slightly better but after
this move big advantage well think first
you have to understand what's going on
first here once you realize what's
happening then you're gonna find the
right move obviously you see that Knight
wants to go to b6 and go to a 4 and C 4
as soon as you can activate that night
is fine
aha why Queen d2
well also it's very important to know
not but he cannot just move the Queen
because the knight is under attack here
so Queen d2 is actually forcing the
exchange of the Queen's and that's
basically gonna lead you into winning
India for me okay so because now he has
to take because otherwise I will
exchange and I will win the pawn on e6
if you place a five I'll go Bishop takes
a five dropping upon so he has to take
and I accomplished exactly what I wanted
it now now two connected passed pawns
with one pass pawn may be called cook
you can hold two connected passed pawns
you can't because practically here I'm
playing with the extra pawn here okay
because this e pawn is extra pawn is
really ineffective here so I have two on
one on the Queen side here but also two
connectors so this is already losing for
him here but still you have to show a
good technique here not so simple Knight
b6 now what do you do
yes absolutely take on the six don't
rush
you could go 93 you want to use D 2
square right because you go to D 2 you
actually attacked the pawn so you're
gaining a temple so he has to do
something because you just want to take
the pawn so he has to play a 5 and now
this move is very important because I
need to establish that control very
strong Bishop a5 attacking the knight as
soon as I put my knight on c4 the game
is over ok because then I have to
connect it past none so just think of it
that way in this kind of positions if
you have a passed pawn to passed pawns
the night goes on c4 blockading his pawn
no counter play so this pretty much over
here now he could have done Knight d5 I
thought about this but then I was gonna
go Knight eater c4 for him and then I
was just gonna play another accurate
move III to prevent his knight from
coming in and then I just push move the
bishop push push easy win so he decided
to go Knight a 4 because at least now he
is blocking my pawns he's not letting me
to just push them connecting but now
there's another problem
Knight c4 we should be 8 and what is the
problem now excellent job Knight is
trapped but again you know I had to
spend I had about 20 minutes 25 minutes
here I had to spend about 5 minutes
maybe a little bit more just to
calculate make sure I played the best
way here because you may think oh this
is totally winning you know I can win
any way I want and then you're gonna
make a mistake so it's still let's see
if you can find a winning plan here I
understand yeah but you also have to see
his ideas yeah he has extra pawn on the
other side of the board if you do all
that he'll take on g4 and play g6 h5 and
then he has a very dangerous outside
passed pawn ok so you have to it's not
so simple I calculated that if my powers
on g3 then I
do that yes now with the power on g4 he
can create outside passed pawn on h-file
he can take and play g6 h5 I really like
this room actually there are two moves I
really like in this game this f3 move if
every move that I played right now it's
one of them because it's a will allow me
to get my King to the center I don't
necessarily want to go after the night I
actually want to play this you know
bring the key to the center first okay
now I'm threatening to take he cannot
afford to let me do this because take
take and my King walks in so he takes I
take keep in mind this piece is still
trapped now he goes king f7 King belongs
where in endgames Center this is no
exception here I think it played g6
sorry so I can get three King f7 can get
three e five now what to do if he just
sits there I'm just gonna be doing this
nice walk to the night and game is over
there's no way for him to do create
country so he pushes he's trying to get
his king to defy but doesn't quite work
okay but first play technically a king
de - is not very technical because you
allowing a fourth so do that same thing
with the king d tree okay and first you
have to do to make the exchange okay
because I don't want to worry about some
efore ideas here
efore takes takes and h5 my concern is
the outside past pond okay so first you
take on f5 now we know he's not gonna
have outside passport we can deal with
the past part on e and F because we have
a bishop at night but if it's outside
past pond then it's a little bit more
tricky so it's important to avoid that
okay now goes here now I go here now I
play d4 here because if he goes here I
calculated that I go here this would be
probably also winning but I'm not sure
if this is the best I think I'm winning
after Knight h6 but I probably wouldn't
want to do this so I would still play
this move and if you pause here I was
just going to go 92 and win the knight
next move Knight is really trapped you
know even if I move my knight is still
trapped not right when you put a knight
on the rim yeah so he played efore at
this point it's over so if ad for but
again I took took and I place here there
the final touch now
93 check correct knocking before here I
have two options here so I was kind of
debating in the beginning a little bit
which one I should go for here both of
them I believe winning but I play the
one that takes didn't give him any
chances that one is taking some chances
because he says pushing the epon
accommodating with the C pawn so you
taking some chances right there okay
you're probably winning but let's take
no chances this is a team tournament
yeah so no I mean in particularly night
night see to check correct now he goes
here look at the yuan square perfect
because now Bishop is guarding the night
so he has to take here King takes a for
now upper piece okay now last try see
for now he's pouring his hopes on the
see any pawn and it's lost but now my
king is for a moment my king is trapped
so I have to be a little bit careful
because I cannot call before I can I go
to before because he takes it bishop cv
is a probably a good move but the move I
played I think it's a little bit more
precise passed pawns meant to be pushed
right and Plus you can activate your
King to b5 keeping that diagonal open
for the bishop okay now he pushes King
b5 Bishop g3 he's trying to win my
knight now calculate calculate first
okay when you're winning just this is
the moment you just spent two minutes
calculate everything you can play b7
it's winning but just calculate why did
you play King b5
of course you want to take the power
right so but you need to just calculate
it's not that much to calculate actually
you just take the pawn now if it hasn't
take only one what do you do then
so he took I took he took the problem
his King is in front of the pawn so he
push I queen and he resigned well just a
kind of a game that I play I I win a lot
of games like this it's it seems like
not much is happening but it's just
basically maneuvering maneuvering you
know trying to you know get you know
some somewhere where opponent will go
slightly wrong so he's the where he went
slightly wrong is the move d5 actually I
think until that he played actually very
very strong so until here I think yeah
until here I think he played very strong
so I think both lines Bishop takes c2 or
Bishop g2 was slightly better for him to
play and still I'm a little bit better
but not in not as much after this I
think you know I've a very comfortable
position
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]